house of the dragon will start a build
up towards the dance of the dragons in
the early seasons we'll cover the dance
itself later seasons however will be
based on george armand's yet unfinished
fire and blood vol 2 book that will
continue with queen rhaenyra's sun king
gig on the third reign and will include
blackfyre rebellion and go all the way
to the end of the targaryen dynasty to
robert's rebellion including the
rebellion itself if you'd like to know a
bit more of what the show will be about
well i cannot actually spill those beans
martin teased in his blog but you might
want to pick up a copy of two ontologies
i did with garner dezois dangerous women
in rogues and then move on to
archmaester gildane's history firing
blood dangerous swimming includes what
press materials describe as a 35 000
word novella by martin cole the princess
and the queen or the blacks and the
greens which is about the dance of the
dragons the vast civil war that tore
westeros apart nearly two centuries
before the events of game of thrones the
greens for the faction during the dance
of the dragons that supported the claim
of aegon the second targaryen the rivals
being the blacks who supported the claim
of her neyra targaryen both were named
for the color of their clothes born
during one turning rogues meanwhile
includes modern story the rogue prince
or a king's brother which chronicles
their early life adventures misdeeds and
marriages of prince daemon targaryen
considered one of the biggest rogues in
the entire history of ice and fire
finally the novel fire and blood
released in november 2018 is the first
novel of a two-part history of the
targaryens in westeros centuries before
the events of a game of thrones house
targaryen the only family of dragonlords
to survive the doom of valyria toca
presidents on dragonstone according to
the book's description on the author's
site fire and blood begins their tale
with the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat all
the way up to the civil war that nearly
tore their dynasty apart in addition to
this few casting calls have been known
i'm speaking of that of daemon targaryen
the rogue prince confirming that the
house of the dragon will be about the
dance of the dragons the targaryen civil
war miguel sapochnick and ryan condell
will serve as showrunners and executive
producers george r martin will also
serve as executive producer i get many
questions from fans asking if they need
to even watch the show when they've just
finished firing blood book the answer is
a huge yes not only will there be
differences between the books and the
show like it was with game of thrones
but after reading fire and blood book
you still don't know how most of the
events really played out some would
think that you could just read the book
fire and blood to know what will happen
in the show based on that very same book
but that's far from truth why because
fire and blood is not a non-conventional
novel its imaginary history book and
according to george armard himself not
very accurate to that this is a book of
imaginary history chronicling the
targaryen kings of westeros it provides
a context and a background for
everything that happens in a song of ice
and fire and it's
not actually written by me it's written
by archmaester gildane of the citadel of
old town who's a very distinguished
scholar but also a somewhat
idiosyncratic and crotchety old man who
has strong opinions on the historical
figures he's writing about so
some of his uh views may creep into the
text i don't
vouch for its authenticity
the targaryens were people
because wildfire and blood book was
written by george rr martin it wasn't
written from him as facts but rather
through the perspective of the citadel's
archmaester gildane who gathered all the
info and as many different sources as he
could and used it to write the book
about the targaryen history some info is
fake some info is true some info is semi
true no one will know for a fact what
was happening in the real history until
the house of the dragon airs in 2022
it's it's not a conventional novel it is
imaginary history
written in the style i don't this is
this book's not actually written by me
you see it's written by archmaester
gildane of the citadel and he's writing
a history and like anyone writing
history he has to go back to primary
sources
and i had a lot of fun with that because
when he gets to the dance of dragons he
has a number of primary sources but
three of them are most major he has he
has
grand master orwell's official court
records he has the
septon
who was kept the the sept in in
king's landing and the red keep
uh who of course is a is a religious
figure so he interprets everything as
the will of the gods and what was a sin
and what wasn't the same and he has
mushroom who was
semi-illiterate and couldn't actually
write anything but who told his story um
in later years to a to a equivalent of a
monk who wrote it all down and mushroom
story of course is always the most
scandalous scurrilous
um
filthy version of events
all of which had to do with
people betraying each other and
poisoning each other and uh
having similar type fun and sleeping in
places they shouldn't sleep
and all of that i love the idea since
this was a fake history i didn't want to
tell it as an omniscient
historian
setting down this is what actually
happened i love the idea of telling it
as a historian in world who's trying to
figure out what happened but he's
looking better as primary sources and
he's finding contradictory accounts
modern historian or someone like
archmaester guildan has to
sort through these stories these
contradictory stories and decide which
he believes and which he doesn't believe
and i had a lot of fun being able to
tell you know mushrooms accounts which
are probably all turned up to 37 and
then the dollar accounts but i didn't
have to just stick to the dollar account
so i could give all three and that was a
great deal of fun and gildane's sort of
favorite phrase that he comes back to is
i guess we'll never know after
presenting every version of the story
the show unlike the book will contain
truth it will depict what actually
happened not the change history fake or
semi-true not what might or might not
have happened fire and blood is a
complete history of house targaryen
written by georgia or martin from a
perspective of archmaester gildane who
wrote it many decades after the events
took place sure most of the main events
such as battles and deaths probably did
happen but as gildan says it in the
books the full truth about what happened
behind closed doors in the privacy of
stairwell's council rooms and bed
chambers he does not fully know and he
turns to many different sources which
usually differ from one another he looks
into the course of chronicles laid down
by grand maester ronsciter and his
successors and many court documents as
well gildane looks into accounts written
decades later by the children and
grandchildren of those caught up in the
events of these times while they are
undoubtedly of use so much time has
passed between the event and the
recording that many confusions and
contradictions have inevitably crept in
unfortunately this is also true for
gildane's two accounts by first hand
observers that have come down to him
septon eustace who served in the royals
stepped in the red cube during much of
his time and spent much time as a
confidant and confessed her to king
viserys and his queens his account is
biased favoring aegen ii over
the second account is based upon the
verbal account of the court full
mushroom who was present at court for
all of them for king viserys princess
and queen rhaenyra and both king aegons
the second and the third during his
reign king baylor the first targaryen
had mushroom's book burned on account of
its scandalous content there are several
main sources for historical information
on the dance of the dragons which are
frequently at odds with each other
gildan also uses source written by grand
maester orwell who had served king gigan
ii targaryen on his council and was
arrested by the forces of queen rhaenyra
targaryen when she took the city or
while wrote his account while locked
away in the black cells uncertain about
whether he would survive the war he
attempted to paint himself in the best
light possible grand maester monkens the
dance of the dragons that true telling
was based on orwell's account using all
these sources which often differ from
one another archmaester gildane wrote
his work firing blood his work about the
history of house targaryen this format
brings up martin's major thematic point
about the uncertainty of memory and
history being written by winners
neither side truly won the war and the
decades after the war both sides wrote
their own biased history books trying to
put their actions in a better light
histories written by the greens they
picked again the second in good light
and rhaenyra in a bad light on the other
hand history is written by the blacks do
the opposite
we'll know exactly what happened in this
time period when the show comes out and
that's why you cannot just read fire and
blood book and think you would know what
actually happened or what will happen on
the show books are written by
archmaester decades and decades after
the events happened using many sources
that in most cases are very different
from each other and most of them are
biased as well the dance of the dragons
was the most devastating war in the
history of the seven kingdoms the war of
succession between aegon ii and his
half-sister rhaenyra over their father
viserys the first throne both of them
thought they belonged on the iron throne
when people started declaring for one of
them or the other their fight divided
the kingdoms in two targaryens fought
targaryens brothers fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons by the time
it was over thousands were dead the
conflict would prove to be incredibly
destructive for not only house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population ultimately leading to
their extinction within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive the
majority of these died during the civil
war called the dance of the dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid
131ac the show will not jump straight
into the fight it will start with a few
episodes of the prelude to the targaryen
civil war with king viserys the first
likely dying after a few episodes which
is just enough to introduce us with all
the characters and which side they
support as the future heir as well as to
set up all the animosity at the court
king viserys the first targaryen had
three children by his first queen emma
aaron but only one princess rhaenyra
survived to adulthood lacking a son to
succeed and viserys began to train
rhaenyra to be his heir named her his
heir and rhaenyra soon acquired support
of hundreds of lords and landed knights
the king remarried in 106 ac this time
to alice sent high tower and had four
more children aegon helena eamon and
daron
in 111ac a great journey was held at
king's landing on the 5th anniversary of
zarya's marriage to alison during the
opening feast queen alicent wore a green
gown while princess rhaenyra dressed in
the red and black of house targaryen no
it was taken and soon all of rhaenyra's
supporters started wearing black
clothing while all of alison's followers
started wearing green over the years the
popular names applied to both factions
were inspired by the colors they bore
rhaenyra supporters were called the
blacks and they got the second followers
were called the greens viserys the first
strengthened rhaenyra's place in the
succession by marrying her in 114 ac to
sterling or valerian who himself had
targaryen blood through his mother
princess rhinis rhaenyra gave birth to
three sons jacarius lucerous and joffrey
valerian during her marriage although
there were rumors that the father of
this princess was not lanar but sir
harvin strong after laner was killed in
spite's town in 120 ac rhaenyra married
her uncle infamous rogue prince prince
daemon targaryen the younger brother to
is there is the first her sons by him
were aegon the younger called so to
distinguish him from his uncle alison
sagan who was occasionally called aegon
the elder and viserys the relationship
between rhaenyra and alicent declined
early in alison's marriage to viserys
since both ladies had been trying to be
the realm's first lady and there could
only be one alison's father sir otto
hightower had also disliked rhaenyra's
second husband prince daemon since the
beginning of his aerys reign
the war began when king viserys the
first died his designated heir for many
years had been his only surviving child
by his first wife his daughter rhaenyra
since viserys the first later remarried
however and had several younger children
by his second wife alice and hightower
the eldest of which was rhaenyra's
half-brother aegon ii the seven kingdoms
had never had their ruling queen before
and many were troubled by the thought of
rhaenyra succeeding to the throne by the
inheritance law of the andals a younger
brother succeeds ahead of an elder
daughter but the targaryens had never
formalized royal inheritance laws for
their new realm after the war of
conquest 130 years before viserys the
first however had extracted the oaths of
filthy from the major lords of the realm
that rhaenyra would succeed him the same
day that viserys the first died aegon
the second followers the green staged
the coup
and he was soon crowned in king's
landing rhaenyra as the princess of
dragonstone had her power based on
dragonstone island where she responded
by being crowned the queen and declaring
aegon a traitor aegon the second's main
supporters were his mother alison's
family the powerful house hightower that
rules old town as well as the lannisters
rhaenyra's main supporters were her
first husband's family house valerian as
well as her mother's family house aaron
and her uncle and future husband the
most dangerous man in the seven kingdoms
and the most experienced commander
daemon targaryen the blacks were mostly
in the north eastern half of westeros
while the greens were mostly in the
southwestern half dorne was not yet part
of the realm and remained neutral during
the war the blacks included the aryans
the starks and the tullys along with
most if not all of the riverlords even
the phrase the starks felt bound by
honor to remain true to the filthy oats
they had made to rhinera and her father
was still alive major greens included
the hightowers and lannisters
rhaenyra had thought the baratheons
would give her support but in what she
saw as a major betrayal they decided to
take on the second the greens faced
their own betrayal however they had
assumed that all of the reach would side
with the greens but instead the northern
half of the reach sided with the blacks
even some of the high towers own direct
vessels in the south sided with the
blacks the tyrells remained officially
neutral throughout the war the greens
had thought that the greyjoys would join
them not realizing that the great wealth
they controlled ironically made them a
more enticing target
seeing a small profit and sailing all
the way to the eastern side of westeros
to raid the modest lands of the vale or
dragonstone the graduates nominally
sided with the blacks in order to raid
the lannister hightower lands along the
eastern coast
despite the greens controlling the
wealthier lands of westeros the blacks
had the advantage of control of the seas
the greens only had the red vine fleet
to rely on for naval power while through
house valerian rhaenyra's forces
controlled most of the royal fleet after
the greyjoy sided with the blacks
however the iron fleet tied up the red
wines in their raids on the west coast
giving the blacks free run of the
eastern coast the greens attempted to
counter this by allying with the kingdom
of the three daughters an alliance of
liz smir and tyrosh whose fleet
assaulted rhaenyra's fleets in the
massive battle of the gullet one third
of the valyrian fleet was lost but the
two-thirds of the three-daughter's fleet
was destroyed
and the survivors withdrew from the rest
of the war overall this meant that
despite the green's numerical
superiority they had to slowly struggle
to march their armies over land to
attack the blacks instead of being able
to quickly move their larger armies by
sea after rhaenyra was crowned queen by
daemon at dragonstone and declared her
her brother a traitor king gagan ii
declared rhaenyra and demon traitors as
well
after being persuaded by his mother
alicent and sister helena aegon
dispatched the grand maestro wild to
dragonstone with a retinue under a peace
banner offering rhaenyra generous terms
but was refused rhaenyra's sons departed
on their dragons to seek allies and make
pacts on their mother's behalf her
eldest son jacary spent visiting the
aryans of the erie the men released of
white harbor and the starks of
winterfell rhaenyra's second son
lucerese traveled to baratheon said
storm's end prince damon led the blacks
attack on harrenhal which was conquered
without bloodshed the castellan sir
simon strong yielded when he saw demons
drag on charaxes this conquest led to
victories of the blacks at the burning
mill and stone hedge and allowed the
river lords to gather at harrenhal in
the meantime jacarius gained lady irene
and the lords manderly borle and
sunderland and craig and stark to
rhaenyra's cause with lord starkey lying
through the pact of ice and fire
lustreus flew to storm's end arriving
before a gathering storm he found prince
demon and his dragon vogar already
present eamon tried to get lucerus into
a fight insulting him calling him a
strong bastard but losers who sworn to
his mother not to fight refused him he
delivered his message to lord boris
baratheon but was refused and told to
leave
boris prevented aemond from attacking
his cousin in the castle but did allow
for the prince to follow him mounted on
his dragon eamonn caught up with los
reyes during a raging storm
the fight between the two dragons did
not last long vagar being five times
bigger had the advantage and rx felt
broken his head and neck washed a short
three days later along with the corpse
of luceries ryner collapsed when
learning of lucery's death prince damon
at harry hall sent a raven to his wife
promising that her son's death would be
avenged using one of his friends from
king's landing daemon enlisted the help
of a former sergeant in the city watch
known known as blood and the red catcher
from the red keep now known only as
cheese the two sneaked into the red keep
using secret tunnels and hidden doors
which brought them into the tower of the
hand their queen allison was bound and
gagged and her bad maid strangled
when queen helena and her three children
appeared blood and cheese bar the doors
and told helena to choose which of her
sons would die helena reluctantly chose
mailer but blood did the opposite and
killed prince jaehaerys instead the two
fled with the prince's head the war was
a stalemate with many unexpected
victories as well as unexpected losses
for both sides with no clear victory
merging even king's landing itself was
attacked though there was no siege
rhaenyra's new husband damon her own
uncle had reorganized and essentially
created the city watch as it would later
be known and they remained loyal to him
after the greens foolishly left the
capital city lightly defended to attack
rhaenyra's armies gathering at harrenhal
her forces on dragonstone moved against
king's landing and the gold cloaks threw
the gates open at their arrival the war
eventually degenerated into a near
anarchy as a string of betrayals
happened in rapid succession on both
sides rival kings started popping up in
different parts of the realm ranging
from the greyjoy is behaving
functionally independent the dragon
riders deciding that they would make
better kings than rhaenyra or aegon the
second to even pet this treat thugs
carving out their own fiefdoms
thinking's landing and declaring
themselves king of have the city there's
many interesting and legendary side
characters as well we have a combination
of varys and little fingering larry
strong being the one in shadows
orchestrating many events and making
kings rise and fall we also have
melisandre is alice rivers amen
targaryen's mistress and perhaps that's
even melisandre herself in her younger
days alice is visions in the flames and
has some great powers
rocalia rindon pirate king is another
legendary side character in the story if
you even have the stories about him are
true he's probably one of the most
insane and most fascinating characters
i've ever read it's a targaryen civil
war so of course targaryens and their
dragons play the main roles in series
but the stark's lane is sirs airing
stallis and hightowers are very
important as well one of the most
exciting 1v1 fights is definitely
legendary daemon targaryen against
aemond one eye that happened above the
god's eye and resulted with both men and
both their dragons dying although daemon
did win a fight by piercing his valyrian
steel sword through aemon's eye's socket
but seconds later both dragons hit the
lake at rapid speed eamon's body was
found
but demons wasn't historians say daemon
died in this fight but singers sing of
his departure from westeros to live out
his days in essos i'm not going to talk
about every single event but all of
these things i mentioned is what
essentially kick-started this dance of
the dragons referring to viserys's death
animosity between the greens and blacks
especially the first fight where
rhaenyra lost her son did turn into a
violent long bloody tale full of revenge
violence lust love and dragon to dragon
aerial battles the civil war lasted two
years and gutted the seven kingdoms with
dragons burning out vast swaths of the
countryside and the entire towns reduced
to ashes the devastation was so great
that it took a full generation to
recover
at the start of the war there were 20
living dragons 9 older and huge dragons
8 younger dragons still large enough to
be ridden to war and 3 hatchlings too
small to ride by the end of the war all
but three had died
another dragon was hatched near the end
of the war bringing the total number of
surviving dragons to four none of them
would live for long and there were too
few dragons left to maintain a stable
breeding population the last dragon said
to be a stunted creature died only 33
years after the war ended later in the
reign of rhaenyra's son king aegon iii
for which he became known as aegon the
dragon bane 20 major battles even more
smaller battles and even more betrayals
turn cloaks and twists all of that this
game of thrones prequel show house of
the dragon brings in 2022 thank you so
much for watching hope you enjoyed this
video and let me know what team are you
on in the comment section down below
team black supporting rhaenyra or team
greens supporting aegon